(upbeat music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two
lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're talking about the surprising items
that are revolutionizing
our everyday lives.
You know, you might, you might say, man,
that product sounds stupid,
but until you find yourself
or someone close to
you using it constantly
you know, like, man,
maybe there's something to this.
- Also I think this is something
you thought you couldn't,
you thought you could do without,
but now you realize you
need it all the time.
You need it every day.
We got a lot of responses.
- You said you asked the question,
you didn't finish the sentence.
We said, what's a surprising
item that has revolutionized
your everyday life,
maybe it's a special tool, a gadget,
something around the house,
work, school, you know, just
trying to jog people's thoughts
because we put these
prompts out there, y'all,
if you respond to them,
we're going to talk about,
we're going to talk
about your perspectives.
- And we do this, we do
this on Twitter, you know.
- Twitter, @mythical.
Follow us.
- Some people have
created Twitter accounts
just to participate.
We appreciate that.
- That's not--
- We hear you, we notice.
So we'll get to that in a second,
but something has happened
to me two days in a row.
And I just want to throw it out there
and see if you think there's
any significance to it.
- Oh, significance.
Okay.
- This is not unusual.
I think that lots of people
talk about this phenomenon
but it hasn't happened to me
in a while and it's
happened two days in a row.
- Okay.
- Waking up and knowing
that I have woken up one minute
before my alarm goes off.
- Oh, yes, yeah, yeah.
- And not just, not just looking--
- It's uncanny.
- Not just looking over to guess,
but having a knowledge and then
looking over to confirm it.
- Oh, okay.
So you have a knowledge, okay?
Your eyes aren't even open yet,
but you know you're waking up
and you're about to look at the clock
and you're saying, my
clock is going to go off
in one minute, you know that.
- Well, so my phone is on a
little stand, a wireless stand.
Not, it's not something
that, I can live without it.
It's not an item that
I'm going to talk about,
but it is a new thing that
I got that has my watch,
my phone and my air, what
do you call them, AirPods?
- I don't know.
- All wirelessly charging on one thing.
It was kind of cool, but
my phone, here's why I know
that I'm not being
influenced by seeing it.
I have to hit my phone
in order to turn the screen
on, to see what time it is.
That's the only indication
of what time it is.
So yesterday I woke up.
- It's interesting.
- I was like, my alarm is about to go off.
Like, literally, it's going to go off
if I don't reach over there,
reach over there, 6:29.
My alarm went off at 6:30,
but I stopped it
literally like 15 seconds.
So I was like, oh,
okay, well that happens.
This morning, alarm is set for 6:15.
I don't get up at the same time every day.
Had different things going on.
That's the weird thing.
- Oh, two different time.
Okay.
That kind of blows the theory here.
- Right, that's why I'm so shaken by it.
- That's crazy.
So today was day two, this morning?
I got to get more data man 'cause--
- Okay, I woke up this morning
and I had the same feeling
and I will say just in full
disclosure, it was 6:13.
So it wasn't 6:14, it wasn't one minute,
but it was two minutes.
And I was like, and I was like--
- So it was the second day in a row,
and you wouldn't set it at the same time.
- I did it again, here's the thing.
This isn't normal.
Now, when I get up at the same time,
but I don't get up at the same time.
I don't--
- I get up at the same
time and there's many times
when I wake up right
before the alarm goes off.
- But you also go to bed
at the same time, right?
- Yeah.
- You go to bed at the same time
and you get up at the same time.
This is not unusual.
But I haven't gone to
bed at the same time--
- I'd like to think I was special too so.
- No, because your body
adjusts to a rhythm.
- No, I'm special.
- You're special in other
ways, everyone knows that.
But I don't go to bed at
the same time every day.
My bed time range is--
- It's not a circadian thing.
- I mean sometimes I might be like,
I'm really tired and
I'll go to bed at 9:30.
Like I'll go to bed at 9:30
and then sometimes I'll
be like, it's midnight.
I haven't thought about bed yet.
I'll go to bed at 12:30.
And any of these things can happen.
It has nothing to do,
it's just whatever happens, happens.
And then the morning is based
on what I need to do that day.
- So when you're going to
bed, do you make the decision?
Do you set your alarm clock?
Because that's changing too apparently.
You make a decision,
is it, will it be 6:15,
will it be 6:30?
- Yeah.
- And how big of a range is that?
- No earlier than six o'clock,
no later than 7:30, and if I need to,
if I want to sleep later,
I can't sleep past 7:30,
I cannot.
It is physically, now
that I've hit my 40s,
physically impossible to sleep past 7:30
and I really, really hate that.
- I can go back to
sleep, but I do wake up.
Well, listen, I'm going
to count the third day,
this morning.
You got three days in a row.
I think you need to keep tracking this
because maybe there's some,
this is something to be harnessed.
- Do you think it's supernatural?
- No.
- That's really what the question is.
- I wish it was, that
would be fun to talk about.
- Do you think this is--
- No, but you can't say it's supernatural.
- Do you think it's
the beginning of maybe,
I could be, maybe I'm like,
this is my origin story,
for like a superhero.
The guy who can wake up
right before his alarm
and harnesses that as a super power.
- The alarm anticipator.
- That's good, this is what I'm saying,
I would be called the anticipator
and I'll start anticipating
things right before they happen
and saving people.
- Well, okay.
Like dismantling a bomb?
- No, it has to be things
that are based on a schedule.
- Like if you were taking a nap?
- Like if a train was coming.
- If you were taking a nap,
and there was a bomb,
you could maximize your sleep
and then wake up and defuse
the bomb right before it goes off,
thereby getting the most rest possible,
so you have a good day.
- I think that's too complex.
I think it's more like, there is a child
that has fallen into the
place where the trains come
in the subway.
- Okay, you're taking a nap
and as the child is falling,
you wake up right before it
hits the asphalt and catch it.
- No, no, no, again, I wake up
right before the train comes.
I let the child be down there.
Maybe seven--
- If the child hit the
ground, it probably died.
- No, no, no, he landed on his
feet and then he rolled over
and now everyone's panicking,
they're trying like, should we pull him up
and I'm sleeping seven to eight
minutes and then I'm like,
train's coming and then
I wake up and then I see
the child, I didn't know about the child,
I see the child because I've woken up
because the train is coming,
and then because I got
long arms--
- Okay, I get it.
- I pull up.
- So really--
- Yeah, that's the
superhero that I'm gonna be,
the anticipator.
- You're really, and
what that means is that
you're a superhero with no real powers
except that you can maximize your sleep
before doing something
that you need to do.
As a matter of fact, you're
kind of like a normal
person that wakes up with
an alarm and does something.
- I think you're seeing
the wrong end of this
and what I'm saying it has
nothing to do with the sleep.
The sleep is only the
way that the anticipator
begins to anticipate.
So you put the anticipator in a situation
where something could
be on certain schedule.
Like, put the anticipator
in there, put him to sleep,
he'll wake up right
before this thing happens.
- But the reason why he's so good--
- Not to defuse the bomb,
but right before the bomb goes off.
So probably too late,
but at least we'll know
it's gonna happen.
- Well, you can take that into account,
you can anticipate the amount of time
it takes to defuse the bomb
if you're the anticipator.
- I don't think I can
get that sophisticated.
- Then you suck.
But you're gonna be well-rested,
and I think that counts for something.
- Yeah.
- It's interesting because just last week
we were talking about
strange habits of successful
people and one of the things
we didn't talk about was
there's a number of people that wake up
without an alarm clock, Oprah,
she's the only one I remember
off the top of my head.
- Oprah, the list can stop there,
and it would be a ringing endorsement.
- I think after a while,
there's no ringing,
that's the point.
It's a silent endorsement of waking up
without an alarm clock.
So you could do that.
- I could do that now.
- Then that is a--
- I can't sleep past 7:30.
- And here's another thing, by the way--
- But I can say, five
o'clock, don't need an alarm.
Is that what she does?
She sets a time and then
just wakes up for it?
- I think I know why this
is happening with you,
because you have
inadvertently set up a system
to train yourself to do this.
You don't have a clock
that's easily visible
from your bed, you have to
wake up more than you need to
in order to see what time
it is, to see if you need
to get up, for me,
I have a clock visible there,
I don't use it as the
alarm, I use my phone
as the wake up alarm,
but I can just easily roll over
and just like, kind of, quarter of the way
open one eye, and see what time it is
and then just immediately
go back to sleep.
That's also why you're
not able to sleep later,
on the weekends or something,
you just need to be able to roll over
and give a little crack to the eye,
oh, I've got 20 minutes, I've got an hour.
- The reason I can't sleep late,
is because, this is a sore
subject between me and my wife,
our bedroom doesn't have blocking blinds,
because whoever we bought the house from
installed translucent blinds.
- You can change that.
- This I've been talking about,
we've been in this house,
for going on six years
and what I told, I tell my wife, you know,
when we were on tour and
I would be like in a hotel
with those, you know
there's like vinyl curtains
that completely block out everything.
And we'd be on a weird schedule
and we'd be on the bus,
and I wouldn't sleep on the bus,
and then we'd get there
and we would have a show
that night, I'd sleep till like noon,
I felt like a teen again.
- Because they had
those blocking curtains.
- The reason I can't sleep
late I believe is because
the sunlight comes in and I tell Jessie,
can we just get blocking blinds?
And she says, well, I'm
gonna redo the bedroom
and she starts telling me all the things
she's gonna do on the windows,
and she says, and they'll block sun.
But I'm not ready to do that.
And I'm like, well, I'm
ready to sleep past 7:30
and then we come to the
standstill and it never goes
anywhere.
- It's not really a standstill,
it's just kind of a
clarification of who's in charge.
- Well, that's for sure.
- Not a stalemate, I
think someone has won.
- Well, yeah, she has won.
She wins.
- Beauty mask, man.
- Well, it doesn't stay.
- Duct tape.
- It doesn't stay on my
face, it's uncomfortable.
- Come on man, I'm trying to help you.
- Do you still wear a beauty mask?
- Look at this face, do
I need a beauty mask?
No, no, I don't.
- But usually when you
commit to something,
you don't ever stop
doing it until your death
in the distant future.
- I think that will
come up as we go through
some of these things
because I'm gonna talk about
some of the things in my
life I can't live without.
And I use it on tour, yeah.
For some of the same reasons
as you're talking about.
Blocking out light,
especially, I started using it
on a plane when I was a plane rider,
and then on the bus, on
tour and stuff like that.
But yeah, never at home.
- I feel like I can still
sense the sun on my skin.
- Never at home.
Let's get to one of these.
Ash responded to our prompt,
Ash says, a wrist watch.
I always just use my
phone and would get lost
in the notifications easily and sometimes
even forget to check the time.
It can be used for time
management, meaning just
the wristwatch, workouts,
when someone asks for the time
and even as an accessory, for fashion.
Changes the game for real, #earbiscuits.
Thanks, Ash, for the throwback answer
right off the bat here.
- Is this a smartwatch or
is this just a wristwatch?
- Yeah, what Ash is saying
is it's juts a wrist watch.
It's a dumb watch.
- How do you use that for a workout?
- I don't, yeah, I guess timing intervals.
- Timing a workout.
- Just timing intervals.
- Or like Tabata, you
know, Tabata training.
- Never heard that word.
- 20 seconds on, 10 seconds off.
- Tabata.
- It's just like high
intensity interval training.
- The word makes me hungry,
it should definitely
be a food.
- Really?
- Oh, tonight is Tabata night.
- Have you had the Tabata burger from--
- Tabatis.
No, it's kind of like, it's not a burger,
it's more like, it's like
a taco and a tostata,
it's kind of like a half-folded taco.
- Okay, but we are talking
about a regular wrist watch
which I don't know man.
- I respect the simplification of life.
I mean we both have smart watches on.
- Oh, yours is loose.
- You're repping the dinky--
- You just went like this.
- And I'm repping the, dinky Apple Watch--
- Do it again.
- And I'm repping the--
- Why is it so loose?
- The Garmin.
Because when I get out of the shower,
I like to of course
blow dry my entire body
and that includes under my watch
because I don't like having moist areas.
- You're not getting good data, man,
that's so loose.
You're not getting good body data.
Your biometrics are gonna be way off.
- When I'm doing a workout.
- Oh then you go.
- Then I tighten it up.
But I don't like it too tight.
- But daily biometrics, man.
- Yeah, I know,
but there's a vein right there.
And I don't like--
- You think you're gonna cut the vein off?
- I feel like I'm cramping the vein.
My kids know that I'm so vein sensitive.
Sometimes I'll just be sitting somewhere
and just a random kid will come up
and like that vein right there.
- A random kid?
- Well, one of my three.
It's like, once you have three.
- I thought you're
like, random kids again.
- When you have three kids
and you interact with them,
it starts to feel like
you're randomly interacting
with children.
Or teens.
- And they touch your veins?
- Just to screw with me, yeah.
- They'll like, and you know back there,
when your forearm is up
and the back of that forearm,
there's that one really big vein.
Oh gosh I'm sorry if I'm
freaking out other people too,
but hey I'm with you, because
they will touch that vein.
Oh, just to screw with me.
- So you think the watch
is constricting the vein?
- It's crimping my vein, man.
- I just think you're
potentially compromising
the function of the watch.
But we have smart watches.
Now, I'm intrigued by this question
because just recently,
I didn't tell you about this,
I didn't tell you about this.
- You don't have to tell me everything.
- I also didn't show you this, but--
- But I do expect it.
- In fact, yesterday.
- Okay, come clean.
- Yesterday, when I left my house, okay?
My shirt was tucked in.
- Oh okay, all right, I
see where this is going.
- Again, I feel like I'm
in a weird phase of my life
right now.
- Yeah, you know what, it's okay, Rhett.
- And you know, it's very okay.
- Being in a weird phase is okay,
what you're about to tell me,
I don't know if it's okay.
- I'm gonna get back to wrist
watch, just go with me here.
I feel like I'm hitting
this part of my life
where I understand that I am,
I'm accepting some things about myself
and one of the things that I'm accepting
is that I'm a 43-year-old man, right?
And so there's things happening,
last time we talked about,
trying to embrace like, I'm gonna dress
in a certain way and I'm
not gonna try to be in style
or whatever, there's other
things that are coming
along with that and one of the things,
just yesterday and firstly,
you know I wear a belt,
and we're gonna get to that
later as well.
- Stay tuned if you're a belt person.
- Well, somebody suggested that.
I have a shirt that's
a little bit too short,
but I liked it, and I was like,
what if I just tucked, what
if I just tucked this shirt in
and I tucked the shirt in and I walked out
and of course showed my wife
who immediately starts laughing,
but because she knows
that I'm coming to ask her
what she thinks about the tucked in shirt,
I don't tuck my shirt in.
- Because as we've established, we know
who has the power.
- And she said, I was
like, what do you think,
she was like, do what you want to do.
- And I was like, but do you like it?
And she said--
- No, no way.
- No, she said, I think it looks good.
- Was it a?
- You saw me yesterday, it was--
- Is it the button up?
- It was the button up from
that sponsor that we had,
that I'm not gonna mention
because they're not sponsoring
this episode.
I love the shirt, I love the way it feels,
I just wish it was about an inch longer,
and so I tucked it in.
- So the shirt is the problem.
- And then I came in and
I had to take a leak.
And I was like, okay, as a man
who has his shirt tucked in,
not as a man who tucks his shirt in,
this is a man who doesn't
tuck his shirt in,
he currently has his shirt tucked in,
who's thinking about
transitioning to become
the man who tucks his shirt in,
because why not, maybe
that's what I'm gonna become,
the guy who has his shirt tucked in.
- I'll answer that question,
but I'll give you your moment.
- And I was like, you
know how like when we go
or we'd be on a talk
show and we wear a suit.
- Yeah I know when we'd be on a talk show.
- And you got to take a
piss right before you go on.
- Don't say piss, it's a little harsh.
For the tone of this conversation.
- When you take a tinkle.
- Good.
- When you don't want to untuck your shirt
because you got it all
the way that you want.
- Yes.
- So you use the zipper
as the zipper is intended.
(laughing)
- That, first of all, let me just say.
That whole process--
- That's a farce, man.
- That whole process of
getting your tally wacker out
of your underwear and out of your zipper.
- Right.
I've seen childbirth easier than that.
- And then feeling like
you've got it all out.
(laughing)
I don't know, I just feel like
I got to reach under there
and kind of--
- Talk about crimping the vein.
(laughing)
- I feel like I got--
- You know what I'm saying?
- I feel like I got to
hit the evac button,
you know, the evac button?
You know where it is, and you feel like
you got to hit it just to make sure.
And this is not an old man thing,
I've been doing this
since I was a toddler.
You got to hit the tank.
You got to press the tank,
make sure it's all out.
- You gotta touch the tank button, yeah.
- And evac button is what I'm calling it.
And you can't get to the tank.
- The way you talk about it,
anyone who doesn't know about this,
what some people don't know about it,
and are picturing right now,
is you're reaching down there and like,
you're pressing a button
and all of a sudden there's like a gush.
- Well, sometimes there is
some and sometimes there's not.
That's why you do it.
It's a safety, it's a backup.
And it's especially
important when you've got
the tally wacker out of the pants
and you're about to go
on national television,
you don't want to have a pee spot,
because sometimes as
you're pulling it back in,
you know what I'm saying,
if you haven't hit
the evac button, it might
decide to evac on its own.
Right?
- If the sea snake is
going back in choral?
He's gonna leave a
little, do they spray ink?
I don't know.
- So I'm in the bathroom
and I've got it out.
- Great.
- And then I'm like,
what the hell am I doing?
Right?
So I put it back in and I unzip
and I hit the evac button.
- Hold on, unzip?
You had already unzipped, it was out.
- I undid my belt and took everything out.
- Okay, okay.
You unbuttoned it.
- Because I couldn't get to it.
- But you didn't put it back in first.
There's no need to do that.
- I put it back in my underwear,
because I had to pull my underwear down.
- Oh god, forgot about that.
- This is so graphic.
I'm sorry.
- Speaking of graphic,
I kind of need a diagram to
make sure people are following.
- I'll put pictures on my Instagram.
No, I won't.
Okay, so anyway, after I took it out,
and by that I mean my shirt tail,
I'm like, what am I doing?
I'll worry about this another day
and then I just left it out
and I came in here
and forgot all about it.
But earlier that day when I was tucked,
I went in and looked at myself
in the full length mirror
that we have in our
bathroom and I was like,
you know I got these boots
and I got these jeans
and I got my button up
tucked in and I got this belt.
- You got this beard, you got that face.
- And then I looked at my
Apple watch, my smart watch,
and I was like that doesn't fit.
That doesn't fit this persona.
Like if I'm building a Sims character,
this guy wouldn't have an apple watch,
he would have like real wrist watch.
You would have an analog watch.
- You're talking about what I've got.
A manly watch.
- No, that's a digital watch.
It looks like a diver's watch.
I'm saying, I'm talking about
a metal watch that's shiny
and has a leather band
or a metal band or something like that.
- A fancy, fancy watch.
- And so then I was like,
do I need that to complete
this look?
- You're going to buy a watch
to justify tucking in your shirt?
You really are up-ended man.
You need a retreat.
- No I just think that
there's a transition happening
and I feel like if you tucked a shirt in,
I at least got to go back
to, I have a leather band
for this watch that I wear,
I got to put the leather
band back on the Apple watch.
- Don't go down this road.
- This is the road of becoming an old man.
You're on the road too,
you're constantly denying it.
- Nope.
I'm not on that road.
- But I am on that road
and I am embracing it.
I am embracing what is going
to unfold over the next decade
and what is going to fold,
apparently my T-shirt into
my pants and maybe my
wiener into my zipper.
I'm just saying, I just feel
like that's what this made
me think about, maybe I
need a watch not because
I need to do all this stuff
that Ash was talking about,
but because I need to complete the look.
- Everything you said--
- Yeah, is important.
- To the decision that is
obvious that you need to make.
You've made every argument
as to why you should not
be tucking your shirts in.
- Why, how is that where you land on this?
- You know what, listen to
Ear Biscuits, this episode,
whatever podcast you found
and the past 10 minutes,
listen back to it and it
will all become clear to you.
You should not be tucking your shirt in.
- That I should be tucking your shirt in.
- But I want to go back,
forget what we thought
we were going for the time being.
- I'm going to tuck it in.
- I want to go back to the peeing thing
because listen man, I
feel like we can help--
- We always talk about
this at the beginning
of Ear Biscuits.
Why does this happen?
- Going, trying to exit,
get your wiener to come
out of the underwear through that thing
and then go through this
gauntlet in order to pee,
it kinks things up, it creates problems
and even if you're gonna push that button,
I mean, I've tried some
things over the years,
and while you think you're done,
you think you've pressed the
button and stuff like that,
and then you put it back in your pants,
I for one peed in my pants
thinking that I was done.
- Yeah.
- And I'm talking like within
the past month it happened.
But I wasn't even tucking my shirt in.
- Hold on you're saying you
did your normal technique
and you still whizzed on yourself?
- I can't remember.
- Is that what you're saying?
- Yeah, I can't remember why it happened,
but I definitely can't just
like, you think it works
that way, but it doesn't.
Because there's too
many kinks in the hose.
It's not, especially
with the tighter pants.
- The tighter pants is the problem
and that's the real problem
with the suits that we
wear that are just way
too tight, but that's what
they say we should be wearing.
- I don't want to get more
graphic, but I'm going to.
- Me too.
- Listen, I'm not embarrassed,
but you talk about
pushing the button, I mean
I am so afraid of peeing
in my own pants or drizzling or being seen
with the dribbles coming through the pants
that sometimes you just
have to go all the way
to milk the snake.
- Oh gosh.
- You ever seen somebody
milk a real snake?
Like milk the venom out of a snake?
- Yeah, that's different,
they put the fangs
over the edge of a cup.
(laughing)
I don't do anything with my
wiener that looks like that.
(laughing)
- Well, I do.
I mean, I don't like,
I don't put it on the
edge of the toilet seat
and then bring a foot
up and stomp on myself.
- Just take the other part of the seat
and bring it down.
(laughing)
Get on your knees, like,
dad, what are you doing?
Don't touch my vein!
- Yeah, it's like you better
make sure the door is locked
if you're gonna take a
knee and use the seat
to smush out any remnants.
- Yeah, I don't have to do that.
Usually it's just a
quick press of a button.
- I mean, there's a lot--
- And if you don't know about this button.
- The button, I don't think.
- You don't think
everybody has the button?
- The button isn't fool proof.
To me, it's like, the button is just,
picture if there were buttons all along
the exit route and you're
pushing multiple buttons.
- Well, that is the fool-proof way.
- Out of compulsion, I'll do that.
- I'll do that if I'm
wearing like gray sweats.
- Right.
- If I'm wearing something that's like.
- If you can't afford a drop.
- Here's where I'll milk the snake,
if I'm wearing gray sweats
at someone else's house.
(laughing)
You know what I'm saying,
where I've got to come back
out to a party.
- Sweatpants party!
- Those two things usually don't happen.
- I don't want to be at my own house, man.
- Gray sweats and somebody else's house.
You know, I was at your house recently,
but I was wearing.
- You've been in the
bathroom for a long time too.
- I was taking a dump,
I took a dump in your
bathroom the other night.
Sorry, I thought that's what it was for.
- Not ideally, for you, no.
- I mean, I don't come
over to your house thinking
I'm definitely gonna take a dump,
but Christie has done a
really good job with that
guest bathroom, it's a nice
bathroom, I like being in there.
If somebody has done a
really good job of designing
a bathroom, as a matter of
fact, everybody on the wall,
in your bathroom is what
you have on your shirt.
- That's right.
- Is it the same artist?
- I don't know.
- I think it's either,
whoever made the wallpaper
is ripping off the artist
who made your shirt
or it's the same artist.
I like feeling like there's an audience
of a bunch of people--
- Watching you--
- Watching me take a dump.
- Milk the snake.
- No, I didn't have to milk the snake,
because I had on black jeans.
- Yeah, you got to think about that.
And that's why I can wear my
underwear more days than--
- How has this become about this?
If you're still listening, I'm sorry.
- I got a lot of backlash
for confessing that I don't,
you know, I'll wear the
same pair of underwear,
I don't know what I said,
but now I'm just gonna say
two days in a row.
And you know what, since I confessed that
and people just gave me shit about it,
I don't do that anymore,
but that's because I
didn't want to talk about,
well, listen, I have a
bidet and I milk the snake.
So there's nothing happening
inside of my underwear
except for a little bit of sweat.
And that's not where I sweat.
So I'm fine, y'all, I'm fine.
- Okay.
- Don't judge me.
Go to mythical.com.
- No one has judged anybody, I'm sure.
We're half an hour into
this podcast and we've only
gotten through one question
and we didn't even really
address it.
- I was in the ad.
Go to mythical.com, buy merch,
we're introducing merch all the time
which means that it goes away.
- We're discontinuing merch all the time.
- If it's about to go away,
you might want to know about it
because if you're eyeing
something and you want to get it
before it's gone, we have
a section for that called.
- Last chance, last chance section.
- Last chance the rapper.
- Last chance section because
we don't bring things back,
usually.
- Usually.
- Sometimes, sometimes we
do, but most of the time
we don't, so if you want
to go to the last chance
section, at mythical.com.
- All right.
Okay.
Oh, you're still with us?
Wow.
That was quite a test.
- There's a number of
people who stopped listening
to this one or at least fast
forwarded to this point.
Welcome.
- Mari said, audiobooks is
something I can't live without,
I didn't think I'd retain the book as much
compared to reading it myself,
but I tried it out with Rhett's rec of
The Stranger in the Woods and I must say
it's been nice, lounging on the sofa,
having a book read to me,
kind of feel like royalty.
- I think read to me.
It's spelt the same way.
- You know, I'm thinking
the book is reading to you.
It's a person.
- I guess either one of
them works technically.
- Having someone read to you.
- But I think they
intended read, but okay.
- Having a book read to me.
Unless you think the
book itself is reading.
Either way, I'm feeling this, Mari,
I too have gotten more into audiobooks,
having listened to you talk
about listening to books.
It's like, yeah, I should be doing that,
so I'd go through like the podcast phase
and I'll go back to the book phase,
and I got too many credits
on my Audible account.
I was looking into pausing it.
Which you have to email
customer service to pause it,
you can pause it for three months.
- You just got to get more books, man.
How many credits do you have?
- Eight.
- Keep it going.
- I only listen to books when I'm walking,
sometimes in the car.
I mean, I've never laid down
and had a book read to me.
- No, I don't do that.
- Sounds like fun though.
- Audio books, man, I feel
like it has revolutionized
the book industry.
It has to be, there are
so many books already,
but I'm reading and I use
the term reading to say
listening, I don't like to qualify,
I found myself over the past year or two,
I would always qualify, I read that,
well I listened to it on Audible.
As if it was lesser, it
don't believe it was lesser,
I mean, most of the history of our species
was pre-written.
It was oral.
You got your stories via
an oral story teller.
Right, it's just a very
recent concept the idea
that you had to justify
that you're actually
getting information because
it's been translated
into words, screw that.
I mean written words.
- You're currently justifying it.
- I'm definitely justifying
it, but I'm saying
I don't qualify it anymore.
- And you're saying
that you don't need to.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So live in Jesse's power.
- You think my wife is--
- I'm just trying to make that a runner,
for the episode, that she's powerful.
- Oh she's very powerful.
- But in contrast to you.
- I have no problem with admitting that.
- So just listen to the books.
- But here's what I'll say.
- You've empowered many, me, Mari.
- I'm listening, this
morning, listening to a book
while I worked out.
I only listen to books while driving.
I kind of feel like I made a choice,
I really like music, but
I only listen to music
while I'm writing, while I'm working.
I don't listen to music
at any other time now.
- I have to split my time.
That's the thing for me with audio books,
is that I love listening to music so much
that I kind of have to
make a disciplined decision
to continue to get into my book,
so that's why walking, my
walks has become my book zone
and there's not a temptation
to listen to music.
So now,
when I'm mountain biking by myself,
I also, I can listen to
an audio book sometimes.
- Usually on the uphill and
then on the downhill part
I might switch to music.
- That's interesting.
Because, speaking of my powerful wife,
she comes down and I like
to work out by myself.
Let's just, I'll be
honest and she knows this,
but you know there's only
so much time in the day
for the both of us so sometimes
we're both down there.
Now what I do when I'm working out,
is I listen to an audio book and sometimes
I listen to a very dry,
like academic audio book
about some scientific concept
or something like that
while I'm sitting there, going rargh!
And she comes down there
and she laughs at me,
and she's like, how do you do this?
How do you work out hard
and listen to this professor
talk about this thing?
- Yeah, it's a juxtaposition.
- She's like, I got to have music.
And she comes down and of
course she's the powerful one,
so we listen to music.
And when we're listening to music,
I feel like I'm missing out on something.
I'm like, man, I had an hour here,
and I was--
- Learning something.
- And if she wasn't here,
I would be making my body better and also
making my mind better,
but now I'm just listening
to dribble, I'm listening
to Alicia Keys say,
"This girl is on fire!"
As I like--
- Is Jessie doing that?
- Yeah, which by the
way is an excellent song
to work out to, I understand.
- Yeah, it's got a big beat.
- And then there's that,
Jessie has put together
this playlist and it's got something,
it's not current.
You know when Gwen Stefani hit that stride
and was like, I don't know when it was,
it was like 10 years ago.
- On that song with Eve where it's like...
- Yeah, yeah, that's good to work out too.
♪ Let me blow your mind ♪
- Yeah, and so she's
got that kind of thing.
- And I get this, I start moving,
but then I'm just like, man
I can't want to get to my car
to learn something.
- You're addicted to ideas.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Think about it.
- Think about it, you're gonna
get yourself into trouble.
- So what are we talking about?
Audio books.
- I can't live without 'em.
Of course I could live
without 'em, but I see them
as a necessary part of
my life at this point.
- Rachel said, popsocket.
I thought they were so dumb till I got one
and I can't hold my phone without it.
Helps when I'm fidgety, but I
don't switch out the designs.
Which you could do.
- You popsocketed for a while.
- I did and my phone case
broke and I haven't gotten
a new one because I thought
I was gonna get a new phone,
so instead of getting a
new case, I just waited
until I got a new phone,
but I never got a new phone,
so now I have a caseless
phone and it's slicker
because there's no case.
- I don't know how you live like that.
- And I was thinking about,
instead of getting a case,
just getting a popsocket.
Hey, we sell those.
Mythical.com, get your mythical popsocket.
You might think it's stupid
until you try it out.
- I tried it out for a while.
- I've got to go back to it
because I've noticed that,
here's the thing, I hold
the phone like this,
and so my pinky is below the phone
and it turns out there is,
you know,
you think you're holding
it in random places,
but it goes to the exact same place,
I hold my phone in the exact same way.
- Right on the vein?
- Yeah, I pinch the vein, now
I'm getting a pain right here
on my pinky finger.
This isn't funny
and literally it hurts.
When I got to my instinctive location
to look at my phone,
my pinky finger, there's a pain spot.
And I need a popsocket.
- No, look, rubber.
I did the same thing,
but mine doesn't hurt
'cause I've got a little
rubber protective little thing.
- And you know what I
think that's what it is.
It didn't hurt until my,
my case has been gone
long enough that I've developed--
- You don't need a
popsocket, you need a case-
- Carpal tunnel.
We don't sell cases.
- Maybe we should.
- We sell popsockets, but let me just say,
this is truth in advertising,
I don't use them and I don't--
- That's not what truth in advertising is.
When you say you sell
something but you don't use it.
- It is truth in advertising.
- Okay, you're being
truthful about something
that we advertise, but you don't use.
- I'm saying, I want you
to have the opportunity
to buy a mythical popsocket.
- If you're into that.
- But I don't endorse them
personally or use them.
I just think that what happens
to me with the popsocket
is it makes it, it gets caught on.
I just want to get this thing
in and out of my pocket,
as quickly as possible,
but I want it to have a little resistance.
I can't imagine, there's
been a couple of days
where I've gone without a case,
I have a case and a screen
protector, a glass--
- Why don't they just make phones
with the case as part of it?
- Well because then you wouldn't
have the power of choice
and also they wouldn't
be able to brag about
how thin it is.
- Make a phone good enough
that you don't need a case.
- I mean that's how Neil
deGrasse Tyson famously
doesn't have a phone case
and when asked about it,
he will take his phone
and play around with it,
and show, that he's like,
I'm not gonna drop this,
why would I need a case?
The only reason I'd need a
case if I needed the phone
to be protected from me
and I don't need to
protect my phone from me.
But I, I'm not Neil deGrasse Tyson,
I may be addicted to ides,
but I'm not Neil deGrasse Tyson
and I need a case because I
do need to protect my phone
from myself, but I don't need a popsocket,
but if you need one, more power to you.
- Jafar says a memory foam pillow.
I'm a tall fellow who has
tremendous back and neck issues
and switching to this pillow
brought the pain I deal with
in the morning to an
almost tolerable level,
I have so much trouble
sleeping without it.
The way you sleep is key to
dealing with chronic pain,
but that can't be the extent of it.
Jafar, I'm gonna point
you to Rhett's video
where he shows you his stretching routine,
he hasn't made it yet,
but we're really laying
on the pressure now.
- Here's what I'll say,
I just went on the
internet and put together
a bunch of exercises,
it's not like I'm some stretching guru.
I do plan on making a video about it,
but you can also just put together
what feels good to you.
- Now, I had neck pain,
when I went to my physical
therapist who told me I needed to invite
my rib to the party.
I believe I also told you at the time
that she sold me a
flax-seed filled cylindrical
pillow that, I put it up on Amazon,
this thing is called
sachi organic buck weed,
so it's not flax seed.
- Yeah, flax seed is what you eat.
- Cylinder neck pillow,
I think some of them do have flax seed
and I'm still using that
thing almost a year later.
- That's the only pillow that you use?
- Yeah.
- So there's nothing else?
- Nothing else.
But I kind of hate it.
- Do you sleep on your back or your side?
- But I do think it works,
it forces me to sleep on my back
and it arches my--
- Could you sleep on your side?
- It pushes my chin down into my neck
and it stretches out the back of my neck
in such a way--
- And it doesn't hurt when you wake up?
- It kind of puts it in
traction in a good way.
Oh yeah, the reviews are
really positive on Amazon,
670 reviews, four and a half stars.
I mean it costs like 37 bucks.
But I'll tell you,
it took weeks of just
saying, you know what,
I'm committed to this thing and even now
almost a year later,
whenever I roll on my side,
it's really not that comfortable.
- So you immediately wake up?
- I wake up enough to go back to my back,
but that's kind of part of it.
I guess this memory foam pillow,
the way this one is shaped
for Jafar kind of helps.
I'm seeing new ones
being pushed on Instagram
right now, it's a memory foam pillow
with a hole in the middle basically
that simulates the same posture
that my seat pillow.
- There's also the square pillow.
- Well that one also has,
if you sleep on your side.
- That's a side sleep--
- It has a big hole in the middle
and two smaller holes on the side,
so if you roll on your side,
your ear is like suspended in a crater.
I'm like okay, this sounds like a gimmick.
I'm gonna stick with my buckweed pillow.
I do think it's helped.
- I told you about the
contraption that I bought
that was designed to keep
you sleeping on your back
that had like,
it was a belt that you wore
that had these big plastic balls
so if you slept on your side,
you'd be sleeping on top of a ball
and you'd wake up.
I actually tried it for about a week,
and I just, I'm a side sleeper,
I want to be a back sleeper,
I think it's the best for a
number of different reasons,
but I don't know, I'm not
having trouble with my back
or my neck because of
sleeping, so I'm kind of just
on my side,
but I want to get your take on this,
'cause my resistance, my
resistance to a particular pillow.
I have two pillows,
they're both down pillows,
but one of them is too like,
your head goes all the way to the ground
and that doesn't work.
And the other one, maybe it's not down,
it's like synthetic down,
so it's actually got some
support so it feels good.
- That way you don't hear the echoes
of the screaming geese in your ears.
- My resistance to
pillows, specialty pillows
is the fear of becoming reliant upon them.
- I was about to say I travel
with my buckweed pillow,
it's small enough.
It's like a quarter of the
size of a normal pillow,
it's just big enough to
go underneath my neck
and come across my shoulders a little bit.
- Yeah, you can take it
with you but that's why
I'm resistant and I'm
not currently hurting,
but I'm glad Jafar has found a pillow.
- Something else, that
I was trying to think
how would I answer this question,
I've got a couple of things.
A pill box.
I've finally gotten a
day of the week pill box
for my supplements.
- Oh so you're not embracing your old age?
Oh, Mr. Pill Box.
- Talk about embracing old age,
I know Christy told
you this the other day,
we were sitting down for dinner.
- You have a special pillow
and you have a pill box,
I mean you should just come along
and start tucking with me.
- We were sitting down
for dinner the other night
and Christy said, "You
are such an old man,
"what are you drinking?"
It's 7 p.m., we're eating dinner
and I'm like, coffee.
I was drinking, it was a
Saturday, I like to stay up late,
so I'll drink my afternoon
coffee later in the day,
I realized I've forgotten about it,
but here I was, at the dinner table,
eating dinner and drinking hot coffee
and that's such an old man thing to do.
But you know what, I can't
live without my pill box
because that, I don't know,
there's something rewarding
about, I mean it's so
efficient, it makes me happy
to know that I can efficiently
just open the Thursday
container, pop them all into
my mouth and swallow away.
- What are you taking?
- It's the stuff that Christy gave me,
you know where the power lies.
- Yeah, but do you know what it is?
She could be poisoning you.
- She could be, but I think
that's part of the trust.
- How many things are we talking about?
- There's two huge black pills.
- Horse pills.
- That are like--
- Tranquilizers.
- It's something that you
and her both over the course
of the pandemic have
said I needed to have,
but I don't know, it's a black pill
and I've got the wellness
that is like a multivitamin.
- You legitimately do not know what it is.
It's just like, my wife
told me to take it,
I drink my coffee and
I put it in my mouth.
- Melatonin is one of
them, but I think that one
is really small.
There's a fish oil one--
- You don't need to be
taking Melatonin every day.
- I'll let you vet my pills later.
It's a small pill.
- It doesn't matter how small it is,
you don't need to be
taking Melatonin every day.
- Just tell me the day I need to take it
and I can put it in
that corresponding bin.
And I could be wrong about all this.
- That's what scares me, I'll
talk to your wife about it.
- Again, I trust her.
I'm not addicted to that idea of knowing
what's in my pill box.
You know, like an old man should.
When I put the pills in the box,
all I do is I take this
for the corresponding day
and I just swallow all the pills.
- Your case that you're not
embracing your old age is--
- Diminishing.
- Quickly falling apart.
- I like the feeling
of the efficiency of it
and it also helps me know what day it is.
- Well that's important.
- They certainly run together.
- I have too many pills, in
fact I was recently searching
for how can I get a pillbox that could
hold all of the things that I take.
- You need a series of connected buckets
like Bozo the Clown's ping-pong toss game.
- And I did, I don't remember when it was,
it was last year or year or two ago,
posted the picture of all
the things I was taking
on my vacation, it was
a two-week vacation,
here's what I'm taking
and of course that's when
the internet experts come
out and they're like,
there's no reason to be
taking all of that stuff,
you just pee it all out.
Okay, maybe, do we want
to talk about pee again,
is that what you're asking?
- I want to use a pillbox,
that's justification enough,
that's what you should tell 'em.
- Every single morning I do
something that would drive you
absolutely nuts, now that
you mentioned the pillbox.
- You open every one individually?
- It's almost a ritual at this point.
- I have a shelf that has
all the things that I take.
Now when I wake up, I take
four things right before
my workout and then after
my workout I take about
five or six things and then
the night before I got to bed
I take about seven or eight things.
- Because you're addicted to ideas.
- And I have reasons for every
single thing that I'm taking,
but yeah, it's almost like--
- You should try having
no reasons, like me.
- Here's this thing, I
open it, I take it out,
I take it.
And I'm like, this is not sustainable,
but it's only something that has worked
in quarantine because--
- You got time to burn.
- But when we were on our
little beach vacation,
a couple, I don't remember when it was,
a month ago or so.
Again I don't have a pillbox
that can accommodate this,
so I put everything into one ziplock bag
and I was like, I'll sort
it out when I get there.
- Oh God.
- And that's when I discovered
that I've got a number
of things that look similar and I'm like
is that the vitamin D
or is that the garlic?
Well I need both of them.
So anyway, if you know of a big pillbox
that can accommodate about 20 supplements
and then has it divided up by day,
that doesn't look like a tackle box,
because I'm thinking about
getting a tackle box.
Because I feel like that
might be the only thing
that will hold it.
- Oh man, I remember I
had a tackle box as a kid
and I would store my
G.I. Joe men in there,
I totally forgot about that.
- All those tackle boxes?
- All those little
compartments, it's so fun.
- Maybe I'll get you a
tackle box for your birthday.
- I loved the feeling
of opening up something
and then the way tackle boxes
work is that you open the top
shell case and then it
has the tiered layers.
- It's like stadium seating in there.
- Yeah, it just kind of
splays out before you, man.
It's amazing.
- Maybe tackle boxes are
what we're talking about.
- A product that I thought was stupid,
until I found that we had one,
we purchased one and now I love it.
I'm looking for excuses to use it,
a dust buster.
- The original.
- I remember when those
first hit the scene
in the 80s--
- My mom got one.
- Nana and papa had one at their house
and it was like, wow, it's rechargeable,
it's a vacuum cleaner in
the palm of your hand,
it's just so much better than a broom.
- What do you clean up with it?
- I think they bought it for kitty litter
that strolls out on the ground,
around the kitty litter box,
I think that's why, I
think it appeared around
the same time as Sokka, at the house,
but now it's recharging in the garage
because apparently they
didn't want to keep it
in a room, so I'm just looking,
like little corners of
the garage, I'm like,
oh now I can get all the
dust out of this corner
of the garage.
You know, it's here, I'm here,
have a little bonding moment.
- Not an old man.
- It's just things that
bring joy into your life.
- Dust busting the
corners of his tackle box.
Samantha really brought
something that I have become
completely dependent upon,
a white noise machine.
My daughter is two and has been using it
since she left the womb and now I can't,
even I can't sleep without one.
I've talked about my white noise machine,
which is not, it's electronic,
but it's supposed to like
resemble the sound of a fan,
it's very loud and I have
it on every single night
for a number of reasons.
One, my white, she's so
powerful and when you're that
powerful, sometimes it leads to snoring,
you know, because you're
just trying to contain it.
And then also, if my kids
are having emergencies
or whatever, I want them to
deal with that on their own.
So I have this thing
and then when I travel,
I have to get my phone,
I have the white noise app on my phone,
but I again, I have some shame around this
because I have become,
I mean I haven't tried
to sleep without it,
but even when I went on my solo trip
and I'm out in the middle of nowhere,
I'm like, I need my little,
and so I'd use my phone,
my phone would be like
dead in the morning.
I don't know, but I like
to think about things
in terms of how functional they would be
as I have said for years,
when the war comes.
When World War III happens and we're all,
you know, basically when
the apocalypse happens
and my family and I are walking across
a desert landscape and you
know when I become meat again.
- Let me just interject,
we've established that
you have already mastered
as the anticipator the art of waking up
without an alarm clock,
yet you're very concerned
that you're not able
to go to sleep without the
constant noise of an app playing.
So it's like--
- Well, here's the thing, as
a despotic apocalyptic ruler
who keeps people on leashes,
you know, which is the
role I want to assume
in the apocalypse, some sort of overlord,
I can't be the guy,
I can't have the necklace
made out of human baby bones
around my neck and then
need a white noise machine
to go to sleep.
That's bad for the image.
- No, I'll tell you what's
gonna save this for you.
Meat again is gonna be like, hey,
Jonathan, get in here.
You're gonna stay up all night--
- Making noise.
- And you're gonna (gargling) in my ear.
- There's no way, that won't work.
- You just got a guy gargling all night.
- That would be very annoying.
- In your tent.
- It is the perfect pitch.
- Binaural, you can have
Jonathan and Taylor,
one on each ear.
- Jonathan and Taylor.
- And then Thomas is down
there massaging your feet.
- Okay, I'll get people to
do my white noise for me.
Yeah, but I feel
self-conscious about the fact
that I need it,
but I'm such a light sleeper, man.
I wake up so easily.
- Most despots get fed grapes.
- Grapes won't be a
thing in the apocalypse.
I don't think that
agriculture can be sustained.
- Should the T be silent in despot?
- So enjoy the grapes.
- Despot, despot, I don't know.
- I don't think so.
- Is it French?
- You mean like depot?
It's silent in depot, but not despot.
- Should it be though?
Just in our little corner of the internet,
can we make the T silent in despot?
- Sure I mean do what you want.
Despot, despot.
- Do you want to talk about
another one or do you just
want to give your rec?
- Oh you're ready for my rec already?
It's been a good episode,
let's go out on a high note.
- Sure.
- Let's not push it.
- Okay.
- You know what, I feel like
the energy's been really good
this episode.
- You don't want to ruin it?
- I don't want to ruin it.
- You feel like it's
hanging in the balance?
- We covered a lot of ground, yeah.
We've dangled out the zipper
and now it's all about--
- We spent a lot of time
talking about that, I'm sorry.
- It's all about pulling it back in,
in a way to not do damage
to anybody's pants.
- Oh just because I said it,
I just want to give credit
to the person who said it.
Fisher.
- We have so many more,
this is such a good prompt.
- We'll do it again.
- Oh you want to do it again?
You want to do a sequel to this episode?
- No, not a sequel.
- Let's just keep going.
- I just want to give credit
because I said I would
to Bonsaibreath, Fisher who says, a belt,
I grew up wearing belts because I had to,
never thought anything of it,
continue to wear belts every day,
only when my favorite belt broke
and I was beltless did I
realize how much I need it.
If I could name two things that I need,
it's the white noise machine and a belt.
Because I mean, of course
if I'm wearing like those
gray sweats at somebody's
house and coming out
with a pee spot, I don't
need a belt for sweatpants,
but for jeans, I got to have a belt.
Pants just work their way down,
things would get exposed
if I don't have a belt.
- Yeah, that must be a shape issue.
- It's a body shape thing.
You don't need a belt.
- I don't.
Does that make me better than you?
Maybe.
- That's up to you.
- Okay then, it does, yeah.
- Okay.
But I don't feel, it feels
like there's a part of me
missing if there's not a slight sinch,
there's a slight sinch
in the midsection area.
Got to have that sinch.
- So you like pinching then,
you like to pinch the veins?
- It doesn't pinch, it's just a sinch.
There's a difference
between a pinch and a sinch,
and you really need to know that.
If you're thinking about
a belt that has a pinch,
then of course you're not gonna wear on.
- Let's give a shoutout to
the people that submitted
some good stuff that we're not,
we're gonna acknowledge
their contribution,
but we're not gonna discuss it,
never done that before.
- This is risky.
So you're basically saying
we're throwing these
to the wayside.
- No, we're not.
You think we're gonna do this again?
We never do things again.
- Well that's not true,
but okay, go ahead.
We can always get more.
- Chloe said a plug-in mug warmer,
I drink my coffee very slowly
and this thing keeps it warm
forever.
She doesn't provide any links to anything,
but it looks like just a white base--
- It almost looks like a wireless
charger you put a phone on.
- That her, in this case,
Good Mythical Morning mug,
I love that.
Oh, $15 on Amazon,
didn't put the link though.
Fisher said a belt,
Klaus said a squatty potty.
NepEnut said a quality
set of kitchen knives.
Having a good set of knives
upped my cooking game dramatically
and I still have no idea how
I ever managed without them.
- Very important.
- Yeah.
I mean we can still talk about this again.
But I'll give a rec.
You ready for a rec, baby rec?
Baby, one, two, three, four.
I don't know what it is about
Amazon's television shows,
but I think and I'm not
loyal to them as a streaming
platform, but I started watching things
on HBO and it does lead
to seeing the other things
I want to check out.
So I started watching what's it called,
Painting with John which debuted on HBO
back in January.
- You said Amazon series.
- Did I say Amazon?
- Yeah.
- HBO.
- You said Amazon because
we were talking about
Amazon links to HBO.
- Painting with John is
just a totally laid back,
comedic, introspective, almost calming,
it's kind of a calming show
that you can just kind of
chill out to.
What I didn't realize is that John Leary,
the writer, producer, star of this show,
he was not only a musician and a painter,
this is about him painting, and an actor.
But he's a founding member,
along with his brother
of the band The Lounge Lizards
which is like this jazz type band.
I've never listened to Lounge Lizards.
- I just heard of them.
- But I heard of them
and he tells the story
of meeting Berry White,
he tells a lot of stories
from his life and it's
while he's painting,
but in an anti-Bob Ross way.
He even says in the opening episode,
he's like, Bob Ross was wrong.
Everybody can't paint.
He has this like--
- He has some snark.
- I don't know if the cervic
is the right descriptor
for his comedic sensibility,
but it's like an
Anthony Bourdain-ish kind of tone,
but he's also kind of goofy at times
and you can tell that this
show is kind of his brain child
and it's just kind of a
nice way to just relax,
hear a guy telling some stories.
It will get you thinking and I don't think
it's for the children.
- Unless you got adult children.
- I think it's rated R.
But I can't quite
remember, I just liked it.
- I don't think that show is rated R.
- Adam McKay is the executive producer.
Damn, Adam McKay, man.
- He's got a lot of stuff going on.
- He does some good stuff.
He also had a show
called Fishing with John.
- I've heard about Fishing with John.
- In 1991.
- I didn't realize it was the same guy,
but I've seen people online
talk about Fishing with John.
- So Painting with John,
check it out on HBO
if you fell like you're into that.
- Well, thanks for engaging with us,
thanks for enduring the
half hour conversation
about finding the special button
in your tank to be able to
leak your lounge lizard.
- You heard it here from the anticipator
and the clueless pill taker.
- Okay, there we go, that's a super-duo.
- #earbiscuits, we'll
talk to you next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist
on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist on the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to
click on the circular icon
to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.